Trascrizione: Paola B
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
(Musica)
Buongiorno.
Vi ringrazio per l'attenzione.
È un onore essere invitato qui alla TEDx
e presentarvi delle idee sulla luce,
sul campo elettromagnetico.
Parleremo di vorticità elettromagnetiche.
Io mi sono formato come astronomo,
poi con il dottorato in fisica teorica,
sono passato da cielo a particelle, relatività
e tutto il resto.
Vorrei comunicarvi un approccio un po' diverso all'astronomia
e poi le applicazioni immediate al quotidiano.
Quello che è interessante,
quando noi riceviamo dagli astri, dalle stelle,
quando riusciamo a vedere le stelle,
riceviamo tutta l'informazione o quasi tutta
dalla luce che ci arriva.
E la cosa più bella che fa un astronomo è
analizzare in dettaglio
la luce che ci arriva dalle stelle
perché noi non possiamo andar lì
a meno di non andare nei pianeti più vicini
del nostro sistema solare.
Allora cosa facciamo?
La luce è il principale vettore di informazione
quindi di solito utilizziamo l'intensità,
le famose magnitudini,
la lunghezza d'onda quindi il colore,
la spettroscopia,
per identificare le specie atomiche
la composizione chimica delle stelle,
oppure la polarizzazione
per mettere in evidenza
certe proprietà del campo elettromagnetico
- perché la luce non è altro che
una manifestazione del campo elettromagnetico -
e vedere se ci sono per esempio polveri
oppure presenza di plasma interstellari
che riescono a polarizzare questa luce
ma ne parleremo fra poco.
Ci sono altre proprietà della luce
che non sono tuttora utilizzate
una di queste, di cui vi parlerò adesso,
è il momento angolare orbitale (OAM).
Questa parola un po' roboante
non è altro che un'applicazione ben nota qui
in Ducati.
Quando voi andate in moto,
il momento angolare della ruota è
quello che vi tiene su,
più veloci andate.
Quando li vedete andare in pista
e buttarsi su in piega
è il vettore del momento angolare
che vi tiene su.
E siete voi con il vostro peso a buttarvi giù
e a giocare con il momento angolare
generato dalla materia della vostra ruota.
Anche la luce ha queste proprietà.
La luce è essenzialmente
un'onda elettromagnetica.
Noi vediamo solo una piccolissima porzione
che è lo spettro visibile, dal violetto al rosso,
poi abbiamo infrarosso radio
e ultravioletto x, e i raggi gamma.
Tutto questo derivava da
una formulazione molto elegante
fatta da Maxwell nel 1863
-- se mi ricordo bene.
La polarizzazione per esempio
è un'orientazione, una proprietà spaziale
di oscillare del campo elettromagnetico
su un piano particolare
o in modo levogiro o destrogiro.
Possiamo utilizzarla
per realizzare i famosi film in 3D.
Utilizziamo una polarizzazione su un piano
per uno e una per l'altro
e riusciamo a creare
un'immagine tridimensionale virtuale.
Però c'è un altro grado di libertà
che viene fuori per esempio da --
queste proprietà dei laser.
Si chiamano modi di cavità.
In pratica questi laser hanno delle proprietà
per cui hanno un campo longitudinale
e generavano delle tracce spaziali della luce.
Quindi la luce essendo vista soprattutto
come un'oscillazione nel tempo
del campo elettrico
la possiamo anche domare
in un certo senso
con una proprietà spaziale di vorticità.
Si possono generare con delle lenti particolari
fatte come delle scale a chiocciola
-- le vedrete dopo --
quelle che abbiamo realizzato in radio,
e imprimere un moto vorticoso
nello spazio di una lunghezza d'onda.
Quindi pensando a più dimensioni
pensiamo alla dimensione temporale e spaziale
che oscilla nel tempo
quindi ci dà un colore
e in più può avere una torsione nello spazio
quindi generare momento angolare
e una traccia di intensità può essere
un dem gaussiano, cioè un semplice punto
come questo puntatore laser
mentre se si ha vorticità
può generare una ciambella
perché all'interno non è definita una fase
quindi la natura molto saggia
non va a creare una singolarità di fase
ma semplicemente il campo si spegne
all'interno.
La cosa più bella è che
se mettiamo una nano particella qui
- sono stati fatti vari esperimenti -
questa particella comincia a girare
come una frizione fatta solo di luce
E ci sono varie prove sperimentali fatte
usate in nanotecnologie, in biologia,
per gli optical tweezer, gli optical spanner
per spostare sul vetrino del microscopio
vari elementi e vari campioni.
Questa proprietà ricorda un po' il fatto che
la luce è fatta come i fusilli
o che i fotoni come dicevo io sono ubriachi
cioè il fronte d'onda è codificato in fase
come una scala a chiocciola.
E queste proprietà della luce sono codificate
esse stesse in numeri naturali.
Quindi ho vorticità zero nella luce normale,
uno, se si attorciglia una volta
nello spazio di una lunghezza d'onda
due, e così via fino all'infinito.
Ci sono prove sperimentali ad accertarlo.
Per prendere confidenza con il formalismo
è arduo prendere l'approccio di Feynman,
della meccanica quantistica, dell'elettrodinamica quantistica,
perché nel caso di un fascio a multi fotoni
è più facile paradossalmente utilizzare
il formalismo di Ettore Majorana
che aveva lasciato nei suoi ultimi appunti,
prima di sparire nel 1938
dai quali ho preso parecchie ispirazioni.
Infatti anche nell'ultimo lavoro sui neutrini
- vado un attimo fuori dal discorso -
abbiamo preso il formalismo di Majorana
e si riesce a far fittare tutto il paradosso
di quella misura che dicono di aver trovato.
Allora in questo caso le equazioni
del campo elettromagnetico di Maxwell
assumono una valenza quantistica speciale
e si può benissimo descrivere la vorticità.
Lo abbiamo fatto su un lavoro interessante.
Applicazioni.
Da astronomo,
mi interessa vedere più dettagli possibili
con il telescopio spaziale
perché in orbita posso mandare solo
un telescopio di una certa grandezza.
Siamo riusciti a dimostrare
matematicamente, numericamente
e sperimentalmente
di poter aumentare di un ordine di grandezza
cioè almeno di 10 volte
o fino a 50 volte in caso di luce coerente
la possibilità, di qualsiasi strumento ottico
di vedere dettagli.
Abbiamo simulato due stelle vicine
e abbiamo superato con i vortici
quello che si chiama criterio di Rayleigh
che sembrava una barriera
quasi impossibile -
non è una legge fisica, è un criterio
ma da domare.
Quindi la prossima applicazione
che andremo a brevettare sarà sui microscopi.
Ma non posso dire nulla perché è ancora in fase di brevetto.
Abbiamo cercato di applicarle all'astronomia.
Questi sono i primi vortici che abbiamo ottenuto da una stella doppia.
Li abbiamo dispersi in uno spettro
nelle varie frequenze per avere più informazione.
E si vede già il buco al centro che indica una certa vorticità.
Questo serve per vedere se possiamo domare la luce delle stelle
È cosa assai difficile, perché c'è poca luce,
ci sono pochi fotoni.
E poi l'atmosfera,
la collimazione con il telescopio
e tutto il resto, rende l'impresa un po' difficile.
Perché tutto è bello quando è sulla carta,
poi quando vai fuori, o in laboratorio
o peggio al telescopio,
delle volte hai un colpo solo
e poi non puoi più replicare l'esperimento
perché ci sono dei fenomeni transienti come
esplosioni di supernove, eccetera.
E se perdi quella, ciao.
Essenzialmente è quello il concetto dell'astronomo.
Al telescopio di Asiago, che è un vecchio telescopio,
abbiamo messo su questo baracchino
e siamo riusciti a ottenere i primi vortici.
E quello che ci interessa è di vedere
cosa possiamo ricavare da queste informazioni --
Prendiamo per esempio una galassia blu,
distantissima, e c'è della materia
come ammassi di galassie e tutto il resto
e noi siamo qua, sulla Terra, via Lattea.
Possiamo vedere o se c'è della materia,
delle distribuzioni di plasma
che danno delle tracce alla luce che l'attraversa
e riusciamo ad avere informazioni sulle distribuzioni di plasma,
dell'atmosfera, eccetera, eccetera.
Potete immaginare anche le applicazioni
sulla vita quotidiana --
con il momento angolare orbitale della luce.
In pratica riusciamo a ricavare
l'informazione dalla fase
e abbiamo un'idea di cosa l'ha riflessa
o di cosa l'ha attraversata.
Un esempio è la lente gravitazionale.
Sapete che la gravità riesce a curvare la luce.
La prova è del 1919 fatta da Sir Arthur Eddington
con Einstein.
È stata la prima prova della relatività generale.
Questa è un'immagine reale di una galassia blu
e viene tutta spappolata ad archi
da questo ammasso di galassie.
Quindi dalla distribuzione della luce
della galassia blu
riusciamo ad avere un'idea
sulla materia oscura e sulla materia visibile
che c'è all'interno delle galassie.
Col momento angolare orbitale
come siamo riusciti a dimostrare su
Nature physics recentemente
- è un calcolo teorico -
riusciamo a vedere anche la rotazione
di questa lente
e quindi la torsione del campo gravitazionale
e misurare la vorticità imposta
da un buco nero rotante.
Ed è un test per la relatività stessa.
Ci sono anche delle applicazioni pratiche
e le abbiamo realizzate subito.
Se riusciamo a ricavare informazione dalle stelle,
possiamo anche utilizzare lo stesso principio
per trasmettere.
Quindi se questi sono stati indipendenti
nella stessa frequenza,
possiamo immaginare di costruire
un canale di comunicazione
per ciascuno degli stati di occupazione spaziale
legati al momento angolare orbitale.
Sono degli stati quantizzati,
dei canali naturali all'interno della stessa frequenza.
Su Nature siamo andati un po' più tardi
con l'annuncio dell'esperimento realizzato
prima ad Uppsala in Svezia
in questo dicembre del 2010
nella camera anecoica più grande d'Europa
Siamo riusciti a generare il primo vortice radio nel wi-fi.
Era quello che ci si aspettava
a livello sperimentale.
Quindi possiamo trasmettere informazione via radio
e creare un canale artificiale
di trasmissioni in radio
utilizzando le vorticità.
E lo abbiamo fatto effettivamente.
Ci siamo fatti dare Palazzo Ducale
a Venezia e l'isola di San Giorgio.
Abbiamo fatto un esperimento dimostrativo
a 500 mt di propagazione di distanza circa.
Ecco qui l'isola di San Giorgio
dove abbiamo messo il trasmettitore.
Palazzo Ducale era la base di ricezione
e riuscivamo a leggere
due canali di dimostrazione
- uno senza vorticità e uno con vorticità -
sulla stessa frequenza.
C'era un membro della Svenska Akademien
come osservatore, e vari amici esterni
come Sir Michael Berry
che è stato il primo a ipotizzare
la vorticità elettromagnetica nel '75
e altri scienziati per validare l'esperimento
che adesso è in fase di pubblicazione
su una rivista referata internazionale.
Questo è il primo apparecchio di Marconi,
questo è il nostro con le vorticità.
E qui abbiamo fatto una maschera di fase
con un paraboloide,
e abbiamo impresso vorticità.
E l'abbiamo dimostrata.
Qui siamo io e il professor Thidé di Uppsala
che indichiamo il punto della torretta dove abbiamo messo la trasmissione.
Qui di solito ormeggiava Guglielmo Marconi con la sua Elettra.
Ed era venuta anche Elettra Marconi
a darci una mano.
Qua, abbiamo ricevuto il segnale-
C'è stato uno show mediatico divertente
e siamo apparsi sulla copertina di ScienceNews
recentemente -- a luglio mi sembra.
Ci sono delle conclusioni da fare.
L'astronomia e l'Accademia, la ricerca
non è che non servono a nulla.
Guardate le applicazioni che possiamo avere:
da relatività, astrofisica e tutto il resto.
Qui, c'è un mondo nuovo nelle telecomunicazioni.
E abbiamo già iniziato
prospettive, telecomunicazioni, più canali.
E infatti cominceremo con uno spinoff
per iniziare ad applicare queste cose
al mondo reale.
E con questo vi ringrazio
(Applausi)